Speaking of 2020, we have really big news
in the 2020 Democratic primary.
There's a big shakeup that's taking place.
Um, it's been about a week since we looked
at polling numbers and my question last week
was, when should the candidate, it's polling
zero and one get out of the 2020 Democratic
primary.
Most of you said that they should get out
now or very soon.
We now have a shakeup.
Joe Biden is still in the lead, but that lead
is increasingly smaller and smaller and it
is now Elizabeth Warren, who for the first
time in this entire primary has surged into
second place.
She has passed Bernie Sanders and she has
passed Kamala Harris.
These are small changes.
Okay.
Bernie and Camila slightly down and Elizabeth
Warren slightly up.
But the trend is clear and the trend has been
that Elizabeth Warren has had a trajectory
that has sort of been immune from the ups
and downs of other candidates.
Lots of candidates have had big ups and downs.
Elizabeth Warren hasn't had that as you see
on your screen.
Elizabeth Warren has had a slow steady climb
about 1.5 points per month dating back to
April and she is now within the margin of
error, but in second place averaging 16.3%
of the vote.
Now in the meantime, she's been helped a little
bit by the fact that Bernie and Kamala Harris
have had sort of some weak results in recent
polls.
One by the NBC, by NBC Wall Street Journal,
another by the economist.
Uh, and one by Emerson.
So important data points.
First of all, Bernie, Warren and Harris are
still really close.
There's only two points in total.
Uh, separating the three of them.
Important to keep that in mind.
These are small changes that we're seeing.
Another note, the distance between the top
four and everybody else is getting bigger
and bigger.
The top four now holds almost 73% of the vote.
16 other candidates are splitting the remaining
27% of the vote.
So no one seems to have any chance of even
getting into the top four other than may be
Pete booted judge, who still at 6%.
I believe at this point that everybody below
Buddha judge is done.
Many of them will drop out after the debate
that's happening in a couple of weeks and
we'll be covering it, covering that debate
live for you.
Of course, in the meantime, the decline of
Joe Biden continues to be something to behold.
At one point, Joe Biden had a lead of almost
a 27 points over Bernie Sanders in early May.
Biden's lead has shrunk, shrunk, shrunk to
just nine.
Over Elizabeth Warren at this point.
And it is a very different race now than it
was a, when Joe Biden first got into this
thing and between Joe Biden's pour debate
performance and some of these strange public
appearances combined honestly with a relatively
small public profile other than, uh, showing
up in Seattle a couple of days after the debate
and saying, um, something very weird about
a gay waiter, which I talked about.
So at some point, and I've gotten questions
about this, there is going to be the issue
of are Bernie and Warren splitting enough
of the vote that combined they could take
the lead over Joe Biden.
So like as an example right now, Elizabeth
Warren is pulling 16 and Bernie's polling
15.
If we imagine that 80% of Bernie voters would
switch to Warren if Bernie was out, I'm not
saying those are the numbers, but imagine
that that was the case.
That would put Warren at 28 and Warren would
now be tied with Joe Biden minus, presumably
some portion of Bernie supporters would switch
to Biden rather than Elizabeth Warren.
So let's do it in reverse.
These are hypothetical's.
I don't want to anger anybody.
Imagine that if Elizabeth Warren got out,
80% of her supporters said I'm switching to
Bernie.
That would also put Bernie in a virtual tie
with Joe Biden.
Again, Biden would probably pick up a point
or two from Warren getting out as well.
I still don't believe that we need to worry
about this right now.
It's early.
We haven't had a second debate.
There are people who are going to drop out.
We are going to see more of that 100% total,
uh, realign behind the candidates that remain
and we'll get to that third debate in September.
Probably only on one stage.
At that point there will be few enough candidates.
So let's continue to focus on issues.
Let's not allow in particular, as I said at
the top of the show, don't allow Trump to
play games to divide the left.
This entire Trump taking Pelosi's side against
the progressive new dems.
It's, it's meant to divide the left.
Don't allow it to happen.
Let's go through the process.
Let's support the candidate that we believe
represents our values and shares our policy
positions.
And let's go from there.
Don't fall into this other stuff.
The polling is going to take care of itself.
Let's continue to advocate to make sure everybody
who wants to vote is going to have their vote
counted both in the primary and in November
of 2020.
Let's continue to ensure that the DNC or try
to ensure that the DNC does not put their
fingers on the scale or, uh, their, their
leg on this scale or their entire body on
the scale.
Uh, and we have the closest thing to an open
and fair primary as possible.
And then we'll deal with Harris.
Uh, I'm sorry, with Warren and Bernie, uh,
potentially splitting the progressive electorate
to Joe Biden's advantage.
We will deal with that one
times on the fourth.
You think the time is now.
Then I want to hear, okay, let us know.
We're on instagram